with the influx of more than 700,000
migrants into the EU in recent months
there are questions over Europe's
external borders and the Schengen
Agreement the current security risks so
tragically illustrated by the Paris
attacks make action even more urgent
given the urgency the European
Commission has tabled a proposal to set
up a new European border and coast guard
system to monitor National Cancer pods
the agency will be able to deploy
equipment and a standing reserve of at
least 1,500 border guards from member
states the new border guard system will
replace frontex the agency which has
come into criticism from some corners
for lack of efficiency concerns however
remain over member state sovereignty a
subject mep is debated in plenary como
lo fue para GC Topsy 00 d fiance tomoka
sue blender a porosity different el mio
figlio mentos literally ensemble if a
country is both failing to control its
borders and refusing to ask for help
then we should offer them a choice take
the help or the rest of the EU will be
within its rights to take action the
proposals will be further debated in the
committee's from early 2016